la parole est à Madame Valérie pcrè
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à la
garde des
saut madame la
ministre le 12 juillet 2013 il y a 2 ans
une catastrophe ferroviaire tragique
frappait notre pays nous avons tous en
mémoire la violence des images de ce
train Paris limoge encastré dans le quai
de la gare de brtinie surorge 7
personnes y ont laissé la vie 70 ont été
blessé dont neuf dans un état grave
à la suite de cette catastrophe des
experts ont été mandatés et leur rapport
dénonc l'état de délabrement avancé de
des voies autour de brettiny et d'autres
parties du réseau face à ce constat j'ai
demandé un audit général des
infrastructure ferroviaire en
île-de-fance mais malgré la gravité des
faits ma demande a été rejetée par votre
majorité au Syndicat des transports et
voilà que la semaine dernière le
quotidien Le Parisien nous apprend que
les juges chargé de l'enquête
demanderait à être désaisis de l'enquête
parce que on ne leur donne pas les
moyens de faire leur travail si cette
information est vraie elle est
profondément choquante la
confirmez-vous les victim les familles
et les millions de voyageurs qui
prennent le train chaque jour ont droit
à toute la vérité sur cette tragédie que
s'est-il passé à brettini tirez les
leçons de ce drame pour en éviter de
nouveau c'est notre responsabilité et
c'est notre devoir madame la ministre
que comptez-vous faire pour que la
justice puisse faire son
travail merci la parole est à Madame
Christiane Toba garde des saut ministre
de la
Justice monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée madame la ministre Valérie pécrè
c'est un drame douloureux qui nous a
frappé vous en souvenez à quel point
nous étions tous choqués parce que nous
avions perdu l'habitude d'avoir des
tragédies
de cette nature avec autant de victimes
dans ce pays la justice a été saisie
j'ai veillé très vite le ministère de la
Justice a veillé très très vite à ce que
la prise en charge des nombreuses
victimes soit faite dans les meilleurs
délais le Premier ministre s'est déplacé
le ministre des Transports s'est déplacé
je me suis moi-même déplacé et nous
avons veillé à nous assurer que tous les
moyens seraiit donné les moyens ont été
donnés au tribunal de d'é il se trouve
que les juges d'instruction ont
effectivement saisi le procureur au
début de l'année pour demander à être
désaisi de la procédure pourquoi parce
que entre temps les les les juges
d'instruction ont estimé que cette
procédure lourde complexe même si ils
veillaient eux également à informer
régulièrement la victimes que cette
procédure lourde complexe pouvait être
transférée à Paris parce que entre-temps
c'est-à-dire en décembbre 2014 j'ai créé
deux pôles d'accidents collectifs un à
Paris un à Marseille au titre d'ailleurs
de la loi de 2011 qui n'avait pas encore
été appliqué et ces deux pôles
d'accidents collectifs ont reçu
évidemment les effectifs de magistrats
et de gressers nécessaires pour
fonctionner de même auprès du Tribunal
d'éine nous avons fait une avance en
frais de justice pour assurer le
traitement de cette procédure il revient
Madame La la la ministre au chefs de
court de décider éventuellement de la
délocalisation d'une procédure nous
mettons les moyens mais nous ne pouvons
pas prendre la décision de d saaisir une
juridiction pour transférer la procédure
à Paris s'il décidait de le faire
évidemment Paris a déjà reçu les renfort
si éri doit conserver j'ai déjà fait
savoir que si nécessaire nous
apporterons dans les tout prochains
jours le complément par la nomination
d'un juge d'instruction supplémentaire
merci madame la garde des saau